Next question.
Sir, I am Arif Khan, a 22-year-old from
Kolkarta, India. I want to know from
many days your style and methodology of
Dhawa which is very effective. How do
you prepare for dawa or what is your
style of research? Because whenever you
answer something or present something,
you very nicely topple down opponent's
claim with very beautiful and unique
hikma. For instance, if someone speaks
an Islam on Islamic terrorism, then you
counterargue with some informative
things that ultimately destroys their
claim. Please tell me how you gather
such information and how you structure
it and how you prepare and what is your
homework. Please let me please sir tell
me your routine and what things do you
take for research and how do you do
research. Your dava affected me so much.
Alhamdulillah. Please help me with some
bit of information or some tricks, notes
etc. If this message really reaches you
then please give me feedback. May Allah
protect you and give mo.
The brother Arif Khan has been watching
my videos and he appreciates the way I
do dawa and he says he likes the way how
I use mahikma and I reply to the
opponent and I top him over or rather I
would say him over because Allah says in
the Quran in in surah fusil chapter
number 41 verse number 34 that you
should win over your enemies. winning
over your enemies is more important than
defeating them to win them over. So we
were as far as a question that how do I
do my research and how do I give the
reply and it has been described normally
if I'm supposed to give a talk on
women's rights in Islam I see to it that
I read all the verses in the Quran
dealing with women then I try and
collect various hadith dealing with
women so that whatever question that can
come on women inshallah we should be
able to answer. So the preparation is
very important when you're giving a
lecture. The lecture that you give
should be hardly 10 to 20%. You should
have five times more knowledge than
lecture given so that you can handle the
question answer. Question answer is more
important when a person will come to
know how much is he in water. So and
regarding knowing a course the best
advice I can give you is that you can
watch the course let's become effective
d international love ring program it's
present in on the ala and if you go on
the alida platform you'll find hundreds
of courses and some of them are on
comparative religion on dawa and this
will tell you in detail how you should
research how you should how you should
present yourself and how can you win all
your enemies. Hope that answers the
question.